[Music]
well hello hello everyone good evening
Grace and peace welcome to the table we
had hoped to have Juanita Johnson be
able to give you this introduction and
welcome but her internet is not working
great she's out in Princeton Texas and
yeah it's not a quality connection so we
love UNITA I hope you're at least able
to watch for sure but so instead you get
me you get I'm doing the message in the
welcome so hey so so glad you guys are
with us um and I've got a few things I
want to touch on all right so first is I
want to introduce the team so we have
got Ryan beer on with us we have got
Mindy Runnels hey bro I don't know where
the iPad is but I'm kind of doing the
thing can you Miniver knows and Gary
miner and his daughter Noelle miner and
Josh Rollins is doing the
behind-the-scenes work so a huge thank
to you to all of them yeah I'm very
grateful for a team of people so a few
announcements one is we've been
mentioning week after week that we have
meetups there basically are small groups
and so I want to highlight on one in
particular so we have a book club and it
meets what's next me is gonna be on
Saturday May 30th at 10:00 a.m. and it
will meet via um Google meets and so if
you're interested in enjoying that
discussion and would like just even or
if you just would like more info on it
I'm like we know what book we're eating
and all of that um then go ahead and
reach out to Sarah John's you can email
her at Sarah sa RA at the table TX dot
org and you guys finally we have a kind
of a video series going called voices of
the table and it's just people kind of
describing what has brought them joy so
it could be even read a piece of poetry
or sing a song or
bible verse or you know whatever kind of
creative way you want to touch on or
kind of share with others what's been
bringing you joy in this season of
quarantine and all that so if you're
interested in that just go ahead kick us
like a Facebook message or Instagram
message you can do it to me personally
you can do it just to the table and just
let us know like hey I'd love to share
something it's a way for us to get to
know you more and and for you to share
with us like yeah kind of a little bit
of who you are so um all right I think
that's all the details let me go ahead
and pray so we can really get started
tonight Lord Jesus we just thank you for
the opportunity to gather in this way
while we'd love to be together
physically we recognize that it's it's a
tremendous grace that we get to connect
here and so thank you God thank you that
we get to acknowledge each other's
presence see some faces listen and
engage in music and worship hear your
word taught got in in connect in that
way and so we just say God we're so so
grateful and I list of every person who
can hear my words Lord that you would
meet them powerfully and draw them to
yourself through this time it is in the
name of Jesus that I pray in
[Music]
please bring it out of peace the storm
surrounding me let it break I too never
still crawl the scene still the rage in
me everywhere I turn
[Music]
you may kiss please Jesus
silence feel the darkness these bodies
[Music]
silence
your name is light that the shadows
can't deny your name
[Music]
[Applause]
the donors to me
his silence be the dumbest reason
[Music]
in the name of the Father of the Son and
the Holy Spirit the name of goodness in
the name of meaning feeling and I hope
you don't screw me in the name of
darkness and light and the Sun
ungraspable Twilight in the name of
mealtimes and sharing and caring by
firelight in the name of action and
peace and human redemption in the name
of eating and drinking and table
confession in the name of sadness regret
and holy obsession the holy name of
anger the spirit of aggression and the
name of forgive and forget and I hope I
get over this and the name of Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit in the name of
beauty and beaten and broken down daily
in the name of seeing our Creed's and
believing in maybe we gather here of a
table of strangers to speak our hope
land and talk of our danger to make
sense of our thinking to authenticate
lives to humanize feeling and stop
telling lies in the name of philosophy
theology and who gives a damn in the
name of employment and study and finding
new family the name of our passion our
loving and our indecent obsessions in
the name of prayer and of worship and of
demon possession in the name of solitude
and quiet and holy reflection in the
name of the lost and lonely and without
direction in the name of efficiency
stupidity and the wholly ineffectual in
the name of straight the queer and the
sometimes bisexual in the name of Mary
and Jesus and the mostly silent Joseph
in the name of speaking to ourselves
saying
this is more than I can cope with in the
name of touch-up and breakup and
breakdown and weeping in the name of
therapy and Prozac and full heart and
breathing in the name of sadness and
madness and years since I've smiled in
the name of the unknown the alien and
the holy in exile in the name of
goodness and kindness and intentionality
in the name of harbor and shelter and
family
[Music]
sky thank you for going before us
and all our dysfunction before I know
that you've even gone to win my war you
love becomes my greatest defense it
leads me from the drive I will turn this
into all I did was pray
[Music]
all I did was well wallah did was stay
still
[Music]
save me so much
so much
[Music]
I
stay still
[Music]
so much better
you
[Music]
Yury introduced me to your love you
picked up a since you put me back
together you're the center of my
[Music]
[Applause]
your name is alight
[Music]
Jesus
sirens fides you make
[Music]
good thank you
that in use
there is always room for light
there is always room for hope and God we
just believe right now that you are
turning our darkest areas
into light
God that the light inside of us will
shine through where we are hopeless we
will find hope and where there has not
been life God your life would be there
waiting for us
we trust you and we believe the work
that you're doing in us God and we ask
that you would keep us open to more God
keep us hopeful keep us trusting and
it's in your name that we pray all these
things a men amen
thank you thank you Mindy beautiful and
Ryan for that that reading that by the
way um it was from PUD Drake I think
it's how you say it's Padre Oh to me
so yeah beautiful
well again a very warm welcome to all of
you who could join us tonight and if you
are here and you haven't yet go ahead
and drop a little comment let us know
that you're here we yeah we want to want
to get to know you a little bit and I
didn't I noticed that I see Eric Nichols
was on earlier he's pretty new to the
community I know he's joining us just a
few weeks and and then I saw also
someone new Marnie core our marnik
s-step and sorry if I'm saying your name
wrong but it's really yeah it's
wonderful to have you and so we're just
yeah we're glad that those of you who
are new I'm so glad you're with us and
to all of you long timers I'm just
really grateful that you're here as well
and for your continued love and support
not just like for me but really for this
church in our collective mission which
is to shift a generation from
reactionary to visionary through the
person and work of Jesus that's what the
table our church community is all about
and in many ways that mission that's
really been very much kind of behind the
scenes of this series run but it's
exactly what we've been talking about so
if you've been following along with us
then you know that the series is title
tranquility cultivating calm in a crazy
world and I was actually talking about
this series with a a friend of mine Ryan
who just did that reading and this week
and we're just gonna processing a
phenomena that we like see all the time
with kids and toys like if you you go to
the store and what inevitably happens
the child begins to beg for the toy like
if you're at Target or Walmart anywhere
with toys I mean this is going to be
inevitable and woe to you if you like
much less walk by the toy aisle well
then it's all is lost and what today
what do they start to do like they're
they just start begging right like I
wonder the toy I need the toy I needed
to live I can have no joy if I don't
have that toy or some toy any toy and
they're just they're dying for the toy
and so finally you give in and they get
the toy and they're just I mean what are
they like they're over them you know
thirds thank you mommy thank you daddy
or Grammy or aunt or uncle or you know
whoever or whatever your relationship is
like and they're just I mean they're
just a few suggest going with love I
love you I love this toy I am settled I
will be happy forever
and they get home and they play with the
toy they're obsessed with the toy the
toy has solved all problems the toy has
brought all joy and this continues for
30 minutes maybe an hour and then what
happens the toy gets tossed onto the
pile of their previous toys now we think
to ourselves Oh kids typical childish
immaturity I'm glad that you know we
adults aren't like that but we are
aren't we only our toys get more
expensive only our toys become in many
ways more dangerous because as we grow
up now it's not just
toys like I eat things but it can even
be people I start to use and abuse
things and people and they become the
latest means to my end but my end of in
many ways of coping with my life and
this is really this is sin of course but
this is as we talked about last week
this is sin as addiction that it's it's
sin as impulsive um short lived
incredibly short-sighted and what's
remarkable is that in the long run it
doesn't even work
and in fact over time our addictions in
our short lived attempts to create
instant tranquility in our lives
actually erode it erode our joy erode
our well-being over time so we said last
week that the path of addiction is like
a roller coaster right the steep highs
like yes I got the toy I got the thing I
got the you know whatever it is that
makes us feel good in the moment so here
uh we do the high and then what happens
when we come plunging down so we said
sin understood as addiction is like a
roller coaster whereas the path of
Christ the path of of spiritual
disciplines like prayer and fasting and
confession accountability silence
genuine connection with others it's like
we said it's like hiking up a mountain
it is admittedly slow going but with
every step you're progressing up the
mountain of maturity with every step
you're beginning to thrive you are by
God's grace creating an inner
tranquility a joy that lasts and so last
week I really focused in on this idea of
of the connection between sin and
addiction that was like three quarters
of the sermon and then I gave just a
little bit at the very end about
spiritual disciplines in the mountain
and such um this week I want to focus
more on on the positive aspect more on
the spiritual discipline side of things
using that
for again of climbing the mountain which
is why the title of my message tonight
is tranquility habits you see I think if
we're honest most people just flat-out
don't understand why they would engage
spiritual disciplines or if they do they
do it somewhat but grudgingly you know I
ought to do this I mean even the word
you know discipline and so we're all
sort of like yeah
I get it I should really I should do
that but I just I want to do something
that makes me happy yeah I wouldn't do
something that fills me with joy but but
what are they missing disciplines are
the path to joy they are the path to
tranquillity
they are the path to all the fruits of
the spirit as the book of Galatians puts
it love joy peace patience kindness
goodness gentleness faithfulness
self-control is it interesting that that
whole list ends with self-control see I
think we gained a new perspective and a
new sense of urgency around spiritual
disciplines when we realize when we kind
of see them through the lens and
understand that they are anti addictive
practices and even more than that they
are they're like the medicine for a sin
sick addicted people in the world and
and as I mentioned I want to spend the
majority of our time this evening on
exactly this topic so the message
tonight will have really three parts um
in part one I want to answer the
question what are spiritual disciplines
part two I'll unpack on how they treat
create tranquility
and then in part three we'll discuss how
to actually like implement them how to
start practicing them so let's start
with the what what on earth are
spiritual disciplines according to the
Christian writer Richard foster he puts
it this way he says spiritual
disciplines are habits practices and
experiences that are designed to develop
in strengthen certain qualities of
spirit to build the muscles of one's
character and expand the breadth of
one's inner life I'm that's such a
profound quote I love his language here
of habit you know a habit is both
something I choose and yet it's it's
also something that becomes deeply
ingrained in me I mean almost compulsive
for example this is like non ously a
spiritual you know discipline so to
speak but um like for me I've now
brushed my teeth for so many years that
I cannot leave my house without brushing
my teeth in the morning like I just
can't I can't do it it's just so deeply
ingrained in me or maybe you've had this
experience with like your hands you know
in like we if you use the restroom and
you have to wash your hands and it's
like you can you feel it I'm
psychologically like oh my gosh I have
to wash my you just feel icky I mean
it's the weird right but it's this deep
deep deep habit and and I think a
spiritual discipline it's basically it's
a healthy habit that both connects me to
Christ as well as creates the character
of Christ in me here's how a theologian
James case Smith puts it he says we tend
to assume that our minds are information
processors into which we deposit the
right beliefs so then we expect the
machine to spit out the right behaviors
and actions as if holiness was an
algorithm right or like a math equation
he says that sort of picture
overestimates the power of thinking and
underestimates the power of habit and
our loves our heart habits what what um
that we absorb through the rhythms and
routines we give ourselves over to the
things I love this line the things that
we do do
something to us as a you know classic
preacher moment let me emphasize that
let me say that again the things that we
do do something to us even when we don't
realize it he says maybe especially when
we don't realize it
in a similar vein this is how the
Apostle Paul in first Timothy chapter 4
verse 7 puts it he says have nothing to
do with godless myths and old wives
tales rather train yourself to be godly
isn't interesting to the Apostle Paul he
doesn't just say be godly be good just
stop sinning Widow put all your
addictions be like Jesus he no he says
train train yourself to be godly what's
he talking about he's talking about
Richard Foster's spiritual disciplines
designed to develop and grow us he's
talking about the quote we just read
James case Smith's his habits of the
heart these rhythms and routines we're
by the grace of God I absorbed the path
of Christ I learn and discipline myself
to live the path of love all right so
let's shift a part to how do they create
tranquility in us I want to contend that
every spiritual discipline has a a
negative and a positive aspect now by
negative I don't mean like something bad
but rather negative in the sense of like
removal of taking a way of purification
in other words to experience tranquility
I must learn to let go of my addictions
right I must stop the evil I do to
myself in others because those of course
bring suffering and erode my tranquility
right that's the negative part but it
doesn't end there
right spiritual disciplines are not just
about being very disciplined you know
being a person who doesn't do the bad in
fact I was listening this week to a
fascinating podcast where it was it was
talking about
the way that that in kind of our secular
world spiritual practices can become
disconnected from ethical training and
it can actually produce monsters this is
fascinating to think about because we
think of someone for example like say
someone who devotes themself to like
fasting or devotes themself to
meditation uh and in there I mean
they're disciplined as all get-out
right they have home the mind I mean
they have no addictions they see clearly
but what happens when those practices
right it's only been a removal process
it's only been a negative I have stopped
undisciplined behavior uh what's missing
there well they they haven't cultivated
loving-kindness and compassion and in
what you can end up getting is a moral
monster like someone who I mean they're
disciplined Wow
but they they have failed to grow in
love and that's why I say there's a
negative and a positive aspect right so
that the negative is the removal right
stop being the addictions stopping the
negative behavior discipline the mind
and in the body but also the positive
move is is growing in love growing in
compassion all right so when I go
through and give you a few examples
these are all from the teachings of
Jesus in Matthew chapter six he mentions
basically three spiritual disciplines
giving prayer and fasting and we'll kind
of walk through this and I want to
unpack um kind of this this negative and
positive aspect in how this leads to
tranquility alright so example number
one is giving we'll start with Matthew
chapter six verse two
Jesus says so when you give to the needy
do not announce it with trumpets as the
hypocrites do in the synagogues and on
the streets to be honored by others now
it's interesting that Jesus simply
assumes this is something his followers
will do it's it's not if you give but
when you give but also notice what
genius insight he has her on this he's
naming that even spiritual disciplines
can be used to build the ego so he says
when you give given secret don't tell
anyone what you're doing don't don't
tweet it don't post it on Facebook keep
it on the DL okay so so what's the
negative aspect of this practice what is
it that's that's being driven out of us
when we give what what addiction might
be sort of given the axe so to speak
well it's probably different for every
person um I think for some it's it's
maybe a sense of greed right giving kind
of pushes back on on the greed that this
simply accumulating you know things and
money for the sake of accumulating make
some people feel really powerful and
worthy and so when you give it starts to
break that that that addiction for
others money is their path to social
acceptance right they want to look cool
and and so in in the spending um that's
where their addiction canalize wrecks it
purchases them that that kind of social
acceptance for others it's that
addiction to to security right I don't
have to rely on God cuz I got a boatload
on money right but what happens when we
give we're developing as as Smith but a
new heart habit or is first Timothy put
it we're training ourselves and
godliness right a habit that says God is
my provision I have it that says I'm not
only going to say I love others I'm
actually going to give towards their
flourishing I'm not a selfish person not
addicted to money into the things they
can buy me I'm learning to cultivate
being a loving generous person right so
that's the that's the positive quality
um you can see right it's there's
there's a generosity right it's not just
about I'm breaking my addiction to money
I don't even need money I'm now
disciplined and you know I've practice
spiritual disciplines and I'm a very
uncontrolled person right it's like it's
not that would be
the point it's breakin addiction so that
you can be a generous person a kind
person right open-handed um now I must
admit I am very thankful for both my
parents in the church communities that I
grew up in I grew up it really in two
churches mostly Lukas Christian Church
and later New Hope Christian Church in
Wiley and I said that little little
country in Wiley in wide-awake Wiley and
the reason I want to thank them is
because both my parents in my church
communities um helped teach me this
about giving and generosity this
spiritual discipline you see by nature I
am a jerk with my money like I'm just
not a generous person
I'm I'm so sorry for my friend I have to
give you birthday presents like I'm not
good at that right I'm I'm an Indian
gram five which means kind of for me
money is my security so I'm not so much
the it's not so much about a greed and
accumulation or social acceptance for me
it is security you know I want security
in and I'm just I'm not impulsive with
my money I keep a close eye on it and I
part with it they grudgingly if I were
in like a normal church setting this
would be the moment where I would be
looking for other positive affirmation
so others would know or I would know I'm
not alone until I'd say you know raise
your hand if that's you man but oh no I
can't do that so I'll just have to sit
with my messed up this for a moment but
here's that here's the good news it's
not madness but but because I was raised
with parents who gave a lot
they're awesome givers they always have
been and because I was raised in
churches write religious communities who
taught me how to give over time it has
created in me the heart habit the the
spiritual discipline of giving right it
has ground into me the idea that that's
a negative in a good way I needed it I
needed it to be round in that that we
are and always should be generous
always generous unendingly generous and
you can see how over time that has
helped not that I'm perfect but it has
helped to break that addiction to money
in my life and has begun the process of
replacing it with the positive the heart
habit of generosity the tranquility
coming back to our series right this
creates tremendous tranquility in me
like I just left my own devices I would
never have known the peace and joy that
comes from giving to others like that's
in fact I've heard in kind of the more
honor with the term I just hang out in
the world and more secular world that
folks who are do not consider themselves
religious at all are now writing whole
books talking about the joys of giving
because it's like they're rediscovering
oh my gosh this is like him I am so
happy when I'm giving and that's I mean
of course you know most spiritual
traditions beat you to it by a few
thousand years that's okay right there
figure now like wow this is a really
powerful spiritual discipline I feel so
happy and that's something I think our
culture misses and so we need right this
practice we need a certain discipline
around it okay you get it
example number two prayer prayer I'll
call prayer in silence now prayer this
could be either a prayer with words or
or as I said prayer of silence um here's
the first jesus said and when you pray
and then he goes on it gives much the
same basically don't do it out in the
open everyone look at me I'm spiritual
so he says and when you pray again
notice he's assuming we'll do this as
his followers now what's the negative
what's the removal not the bad but the
negative aspect the removal aspect of
prayer well if you ever tried to pray
then you know that you have to let what
you have to let go of is a wandering
mind right you're praying and then
suddenly that thing that person that
situation it comes to mind and it just
draws you into distraction you're
thinking about like I wonder maybe for
breakfast or what a matter where or
whatever right so that's kind of the the
negative thing of Prayer is that it
disciplines the mind right it focuses I
learn how to focus how to focus on God
how to tune in to what's going on in my
own soul right that's powerful um
however as I talked about earlier simply
becoming a person of iron whittle and
focus in a mind free of distraction that
is not enough in fact you could be again
the most disciplined monkish amazing
pray or meditate erever
and be a total moral monster so um we
gotta move beyond just the negative to
the positive what else is prayer about
in the positive sense it's about
cultivating a love for God right it's
about cultivating a love for others I'm
not only disciplining the mind but I am
moving towards God in love and when I
pray for others I am moving towards them
in love I'm praying Oh God
would you hold them would you heal them
which you love them God draw draw me
draw them to yourself God bring healing
to our society God end our our racism
God end our greed I'm end our
individualism these things that rip us
apart from each other help us to love
right that's what's going on there
that's not just about disciplining the
mind that's the positive move that
that's cultivating love in compassion
all right third example fasting again
jesus said when you fast and so he's of
course assuming there are going to be
seasons when we give up either food or
other things we enjoy now I will admit
you know I practice like fasting this is
clearly like much more clearly slanted
towards what I've been calling the
negative or the towards the stopping of
something um you know perhaps more than
all even all the others this is like a
very much an anti addiction practice but
what's the positive side of fasting well
when done well it cultivates a deep
reliance upon God I don't know if you've
ever fasted on like food or something
that you you know
crave uh it's very difficult right and
so it creates in you the sense of Lord I
need you like I had no idea I was so
weak and fasting can actually call to me
a deeper Alliance on God as well as a
humility in ourselves like we can all
think you know we're Superman or
superwoman until we fast and then we're
like oh gosh hey baby
and that's not always a bad thing right
okay so those are the three spiritual
disciplines just three I could of course
go on and on all evening with like there
are just many many spiritual disciplines
um like everything from solitude you
know gratitude which we'll be touching
on next week
simplicity the discipline of study right
filling our minds or the truth of
Scripture like on Omega go um but I hope
this has at least just started to get
your wheels kind of turning a bit and
that it's helped to start to stoke a
desire in you for this life because as
Richard Foster says the desperate need
today is not for a greater number of
intelligent people or gifted people but
for deep people and how do we get there
that we've got to climb the mountain of
spiritual practice by God's grace with
him aiding us every step of the way
we've got to take intentional steps to
grow in him to develop our soul so I
want to close by by telling you how to
begin engaging spiritual disciplines I
want to give you a bit of a metaphor so
Jim Collins in his book great by choice
it's actually a business book but it's
quite insightful and he in it he unpacks
this idea he calls it the 20-mile March
and this is how he describes it he says
imagine that you're standing in the
Pacific Ocean in the city of San Diego
and you are about to embark on a 3,000
mile journey by foot to the tip of Maine
and on the first day you
marks 20 miles in the second day you
marched 20 miles in the third day you
march 20 miles in this continues for a
few a few weeks and then the weather
cools and you know what you're still
feeling good I mean like real good and
what did you tended to do you're tempted
to try and go farther but you say no
just 20 miles and then you reach the
mountains of Colorado congratulations
that's quite a feat if you encounter
snow and the wind and freezing cold
temperatures and all you want to do at
that point is stay in your stinking
sleeping bag but what do you do you get
up and you march 20 miles and on and on
and on you go and eventually 20 miles at
a time you reach the state of man all
right now imagine there was another
person standing with you on that exact
same day in San Diego and they are
pumped to get started and so right out
of the gate they go 40 miles that first
day but then the next day they face 100
degree heat and so they kind of you know
they hang out you know waiting for
cooler weather and then imagine that
this person now maintains this pattern
on big days when the weather is
favorable or I should say big days when
the weather is favorable right they go
big um and but then when the weather is
unfavorable and then they do nothing and
then this person imagines they hit
Colorado and now your friend he's
exhausted it's freezing and so he just
you just stinking hunkers down until
spring but by the time he reaches Kansas
City what have you done you're already
to Maine why because you went 20 miles
at a time right it's there was a
discipline to what you were doing not
too hard and not too easy right and I
think it's exist
actly this way with spiritual
disciplines I mean we hear messages like
this or like the one last week and this
week and of course we're all tempted to
like we're gonna quit all our addictions
tomorrow and I'm gonna start praying for
an hour a day and reading through the
whole Bible in a year and I just wanna
say like tap the brakes slow down what
you need identify is figure out what
your 20-mile March is and I mean for you
maybe when it comes to Scripture maybe
it's reading one chapter a day like
you're gonna read one chapter the Bible
a day and it may be or maybe it's like
five minutes of Prayer or 10 minutes
maybe it's finding accountability to
quit one primary addiction in your life
but whatever it is
um choose your 20-mile March and do not
let anything deter you and I I promise
when you do that you will find yourself
day by day
climbing that mountain growing in the
character of Christ um growing in love
for God in others and it is as someone
who's been doing this journey for a
while it it's amazing it's the journey
of a lifetime
alright let me pray for us bow your
heads close your eyes um Lord Jesus I
lift up my my friends and all the folks
who can hear my voice and I pray first
off God that you would set them free
from everything that entangles and holds
them down and and I pray secondly God
that that you would um fill them with
energy and passion and most of all with
resilience God may your Holy Spirit fill
them and give them resilience to
maintain the March to be in this to stay
on the path every single day to keep
progressing to keep moving forward and
God I thank you for what you're gonna do
in our community as a result of more and
more people stayin on this path got so
give us energy give us joy in the
journey create in us tranquility Lord
that's our prayer the name of Jesus I
pray amen
Lord I find you in the seeking Lord I
find you in the doubt and to know you is
to love you and to know so little else I
need Oh
[Music]
Oh
one two three four hands you know you
- love you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
but I find you
[Music]
[Applause]
my life before you go
you're great inside
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
yeah like go away
guys before me your life I'll fight for
a needle
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
me
ah
[Music]
well thank y'all so much thank you for
joining us tonight
don't forget about meetups or small
groups if you'd like to join one you
could use some support in this season go
ahead kick us a Facebook message online
and let us know and we'll get you hooked
up with one finally we're gonna keep the
live stream going just for a few minutes
so you can say goodbye to one another
and you know all that so be sure to
chime in if you haven't already tell
people you love them or just that you
were here and yeah because we'd love to
know that that you connected with us
so let me I'm go ahead and send you all
out with this benediction you are God's
servants you're gifted with dreams
you're gifted with visions and upon you
rest the grace of God like flames of
fire go love serve the Lord in the
strength of the Holy Spirit god bless
you all have a great great week
you